[Applaudissements]
ta vie c'est quand même dingue je suis
capable d'affronter de me retrouver face
à un taureau stein d'une tonne
mais là me retrouver devant vous
aujourd'hui je suis complètement
tétanisés mais bon je vais essayer de
faire mieux qu'hier j'ai pas su sortir
un molière et pourtant il y avait
personne dans la salle
voilà mais bon on en rit faire passer
mon message est plus fort que tout et
j'ai vraiment envie d'y arriver
et puis en plus leur avance et je
suppose que vous commencez tout
doucement à avoir faim je sais c'est un
peu un cliché mais nous avons tous
besoin de manger tous les jours que ce
soit du pain du beurre du fromage de la
confiture de la viande des bonbons de la
bière tous et cette réalité et ce besoin
de consommer de 7,2 de manger au
quotidien nous ramène à notre réalité en
tant que consommateur à l'impact que
nous avons et aux conséquences que cela
peut avoir
et cela nous nous renvoie face à une
réalité d'une agriculture classique et
on conseillère des conséquences que l'on
peut plus nier aujourd'hui à l'heure
actuelle il y à 795 millions personnes
dans le monde qui souffrent de la faim
il ya 30 à 40 % de la nourriture qui est
gaspillée et qui va à la poubelle et a
les problèmes de la déforestation
amazonienne et gaz à effet de serre la
pollution due aux produits
phytosanitaires l'antibiorésistance et
j'en passe mais rassurez-vous
aujourd'hui j'ai pas vous parler de ça
et je vais laisser ça aux experts ce
dont moi j'ai envie de vous parler
aujourd'hui c'est de la c2 d'une autre
agriculture celle que je connais puisque
je tente de la pratiquer avec ma famille
au quotidien dans notre ferme familiale
et oui nous sommes la quatrième
génération de henin a loué la ferme du
château des clés lorsque je rencontre
quelqu'un pour la première fois et que
je lui dis que je suis agriculteur et en
plus producteurs laitiers alors là je
vois directement dans son regard de la
pitié et de la compenser
de l'avis de la pitié dans son regard
mais après je dis que j'en l'agriculture
biologique et la savoie une petite lueur
d'espoir qui apparaît mec mais
concrètement qu'est ce que c'est être
agriculteur la base de mon métier
le b à ba c'est la terre c'est cultiver
cette terre cette terre à laquelle à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui on a donné une
valeur complètement folle complètement
démentiel est complètement sûr fait
alors que sa seule vraie et unique
valeur c'est la capacité et corps à un
agriculteur à maîtriser l'ensemble des
facteurs qu'il qu'il faut connaître pour
produire de la nourriture à destination
de l'être humain
rendez vous compte que dans un gramme de
terres cultivées il y à plus de 1
milliard d'êtres vivants
c'est un milliard d'êtres vivants
représente plus de cent mille espèces ah
ben voilà c'est ça mon job
mon job à la base mon job c'est de
cultiver cette vie microbienne
c'est de l'entretenir et quand on
cherche à entretenir cette vie
microbienne
mais la première chose qu'on doit faire
c'est la nourrir et pour nourrir cette
vie microbienne
on doit être capable de comprendre
comment fonctionne la matière organique
comment la travailler c'est le fameux
composent dont vous entendez parler
souvent alors ce en agriculture il faut
avoir une chose en tête c'est que rien
ne se perd et rien de secret c'est comme
dans tout mais c'est vraiment encore
plus vrai en agriculture et lorsque vous
exportez quelque chose de votre sol
vous devez être capable de rapporter ce
que vous avez porté alors là vous avez
deux possibilités soit vous choisissez
les intrants chimiques soit vous
choisissez les intrants naturel et là il
faut prendre conscience d'une chose
c'est qu'en agriculture même si ça va
prendre du temps
tout ce que vous allez faire va avoir
des conséquences un jour ou l'autre et
ses conséquences il faudrait être
capable de les assumer voilà ça c'est le
sol c'est en gros comment ça fonctionne
et après il faut faire le choix d'une
culture
une fois qu'on a fait le choix d'une
culture il faut choisir quelle espèce
choisir il faut choisir
il faut savoir quels sont ses besoins
quelles vont être les maladies
auxquelles vont-elles d'une vénérable
comment faire pour l'en prémunir par
rapport à ces maladies
quels sont les lequel est le contexte
pédoclimatiques et s'adapter et toute
une série d'autres choses qui nous
permettre
d'arriver à produire que ce soit des
légumes des céréales de l'erp à
destination des animaux etc
vous l'aurez compris on est en équilibre
en agriculture tout est une question
d'équilibré
il ya tout eu il ya énormément de
facteurs qui entrent en considération et
il faut être capable de jouer dedans
tenir compte et donc vous l'aurez
compris mon premier métier à moi en tant
qu'agriculteur c'est d'être
équilibristes non je plaisante c'est
d'être à grenoble mais à l'heure
actuelle est très gros nomme mais c'est
pas suffisant il faut aussi que je gagne
ma vie de mon métier
une seule règle basique pour arriver à
gagner sa vie et je vous rassure elle
est basique mais elle est très difficile
à atteindre dans mon domaine c'est de
vendre plus cher votre production qu'est
ce que nous a coûté à produire et ça
pourrait arriver c'est tout un programme
alors on a deux possibilités la première
ont choisi de travailler avec
l'industrie agroalimentaire et alors là
on espère qu'ils ont l'extrême amabilité
de vous payer dignement pour le travail
que vous avez fourni et pour la qualité
de vos produits et moi ça fait plus de
dix ans que je suis agriculteur et j'ai
pris beaucoup de claques et j'ai appris
que ça ne fonctionne pas ça ne
fonctionne pas comme ça il ya une autre
voie celle qu'on a choisi de prendre
avec ma famille est d'essayer de
reprendre notre sort en main nous avons
donc décidé de fixer le prix de notre
production nous mêmes mais pour ça avant
d'en arriver à cela il ya plusieurs
étapes à franchir et d'autres
compétences à acquérir
j'ai d'abord dû nous avons d'abord dû
transformer nos produits avant les
commercialiser il faut apprendre à les
transformer et ça c'est toute une série
de démarches à entreprendre de compo de
nouvelles compétences à acquérir mais
nous avions de la chance c'est que les
télés les générations qui nous ont
précédés sur la ferme nous ont transmis
le plaisir de faire de bons produits de
comment les faire est de savoir comment
les vendre parce que si on peut
apprendre ça sur les bancs de l'école
on ne peut pas tout apprendre et à
toutes il ya toute une série de choses
que l'on apprend seulement par essai
erreur
et alors là il faut faire attention à ce
que les erreurs ne vous ruine pas
ensuite une fois que vous êtes capable
de transformer vous êtes formés mais là
il ya encore d'autres compétences à
acquérir
nous avons dû apprendre à être maçon
électricien menuisier car à l'heure etc
bah ouais comme on n'avait pas trop de
moyens et que les banques ne voulaient
pas nous suivre il a bien fallu
construire notre imagerie nous mêmes et
ça je peux vous assurer que c'était une
période ça a été des mois chargé et que
notre dos en a pris un coup mais bon
voilà la fromagerie est construite ça y
est les choses sérieuses peuvent
commencer
nous avons dû apprendre à communiquer
parce que ça c'est tout un art aussi à
nous avons dû apprendre à communiquer à
gérer la logistique à gérer les
consommateurs que ce soit en bien ou en
mal
il a fallu envoyer les factures recevoir
les factures continuer à transformer
continue à s'améliorer au niveau de la
transformation pour toujours essayer de
trouver les pourquoi les commet bref
toute une série de choses mais le plus
important dans notre métier c'est de
bien faire ses comptes
et là il faut être un bon comptable et
donc il faut savoir et surtout au début
parce que la marge de manoeuvre a été
très étroite et là ça n'a pas manqué
c'était en 2015 il ya la crise du lait
qui s'est installée et la sécheresse bon
ça fait plaisir à tout le monde
il faisait beau mais pour nous ce n'est
pas très réjouissant lemoine d'avril et
de mai qu'on vient de passer vous assure
que ça n'a pas été rose pour nous
enfin bon et là qu'est ce qui s'est
passé sur cette année là on a perdu
entre 70 et 80 mille euros sur notre
chiffre d'affaires alors là c'est une
autre facette du métier d'agriculteur
mais il faut avoir les reins solides
un mental d'acier et une famille et des
amis proches sur qui on peut compter
dans les moments difficiles mais bon
c'est pas tout ce n'est pas encore fini
nous sommes agronome transformateurs
distributeurs mais nous avons aussi une
autre réalité à notre un autre métier et
la salle est plus difficile à expliquer
et plus difficile à partager parce que
c'est pas quelque chose de palpable et
en plus notre société moderne qui adore
tout contrôler tout maîtriser belle
savent ça nous c'est quelque chose qui
est difficile
donc je vais vous donner un exemple
d'une expérience que j'ai vécue c'est
pas catastrophique
c'est un samedi après-midi fait beau le
journée idéale mais mon ami a choisi de
se marier
ce jour là bas qu'est ce que j'ai fait
je me suis levé plus tôt à 5 heures du
matin pour traire mes vaches pour
prendre de l avance et pour être dans
les temps
génial j'étais prêt j'avais mis mon beau
costume mais avant de partir j'ai été
voir si tout allait bien au niveau des
vaches
hélas ça n'a pas raté il y en a une caf
et son veau à ce moment là bas il a
fallu que j'occupe j'ai perdu une heure
est plutôt que d'être en avance j
arrivais dernier la voilà c'est ça la
réalité de mon métier c'est travailler
avec du vivant c'est plein de facteurs
différents et toute une série de
facteurs qu'on ne peut pas maîtriser et
ça à l'heure d'aujourd'hui c'est plus
difficile à accepter c'est toutes les
contraintes qui vont autour du monde
agricole et que la société a plus de mal
à comprendre quand tout va bien ça va
mais quand on est confronté à ce facteur
qu'on peut pas maîtriser
on râle sur l'agriculteur mais il n'est
pas toujours responsable de cela et donc
c'est ça ma réalité c'est qu'on
travaille avec du vivant
mais qu'on le veuille ou non notre notre
société moderne
si elle existe c'est grâce à ceux vivant
et cette société moderne si elle existe
c'est grâce à ceux vivant
tenez par exemple sur notre ferme chez
nous il ya 75 hectares avec ses 75
hectares de terres de moi de ne pas être
pas très bonne qualité nous arrivons à
nourrir 60 vaches les un troupeau de 60
vaches laitières avec soin ses 60 vaches
laitières
nous arrivons à produire 4000 litres de
lait et 5000 kg de viande
bon ben je sais quatre mille 4000 litres
de 400 mille litres de lait pour vous à
l'année ça ne représente pas grand chose
pour vous aider à savoir visualiser ce
que ça représente
mais sachez que 400 minutes de l'est
c'est les besoins quotidiens en produits
laitiers de 5500 personnes soit 10 fois
la salle ici présente donc tous les
jours mes frères ma soeur et moi et mon
père dont quatre emplois créés on arrive
à fournir les besoins en produits
laitiers de 10 fois les le nombre de
personnes ici présentes
c'est quand même pas mal et encore on
est une petite ferme
alors mais bon ça c'est pas tout il ya
aussi le futur comment essayer de
préparer de penser et de prévoir le
futur pas dans le futur on aura encore
plus besoin que jamais des agriculteurs
pour répondre à tous les défis qui sont
qui se présente à nous faut savoir qu'en
2050 nous serons 10 milliards
d'individus
est-ce que nous rêvons tous est une
société beaucoup plus juste est beaucoup
plus équilibré mais une société beaucoup
plus juste et équitable
ça commence avant tout par les gens qui
mangent à leur faim des produits de
qualité et de faire tout ça en
préservant l'environnement
alors là on se pose une question en tant
qu'agriculteur mais on a envie de
contribuer à ce changement
on a envie d'y participer et quel est
notre rôle au motion hélas une sur une
petite ferme de 75 hectares qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire par rapport à ça le
changement on est tous d'accord qui doit
très doux globale sur la planète
mais avant d'être globale le changement
doit s'opérer dans chaque note chaque
ferme et c'est ça ce que moi je peux
faire en tant qu'agriculteur ces deux
d'essayer de changer les choses au
niveau d'un ferme mais imaginez un petit
peu le défi qui se présente à nous
on va être il va y avoir plus de
personnes à nourrir il y aura moins
terres arables il va falloir se passer
des produits chimiques pour préserver
l'environnement et la santé humaine et
en plus de cela il va falloir répondre
aux nouveaux défis énergétiques qui se
présente à nous
il ya du boulot hélas la première chose
à faire c'est comment utiliser beaucoup
mieux l'espace disponible
comment réfléchir beaucoup mieux et là
je vous rappelle tous toutes les
compétences qu'il a fallu acquérir
surtout au niveau agronomique
c'est là qu'il faut être capable de les
utiliser au mieux mais alors comment
utiliser beaucoup mieux l'espace bétonné
par exemple chez nous dans notre ferme
il ya 75 hectares sur ces 75 ha j'ai dit
qu'ils n'étaient pas bons mais au final
y en a quand même cinq qui sont de bonne
qualité
sur ses 5 hectares de terre nous serions
capables de frère de produire des
légumes en production maraîchère
nous arrivons à créer cinq emplois
supplémentaires et en plus de ça nous
sommes capables de produire les besoins
en légumes quotidiens de 2000 personnes
ensuite avec les 70 hectares restants
nous serions capables de mettre 15
hectares
de céréales en rotation avec 20 hectares
de prairies temporaires
à cela se rajoute 35 hectares de
prairies permanentes
il faut savoir que les prairies
permanentes c'est un paradis pour la
biodiversité et en même temps ça permet
de fixer des quantités astronomiques de
carbone dans le sol
donc ils ne seront plus libéré comment
qui va directement plusieurs dans le sol
dans l'air pour être fixé avec cet os
avec toutes ces prairies nous soyons
capables plus de nourrir 60 vaches
laitières mais 40 vaches laitières en
autonomie alimentaire à la ferme avec
ses 40 vaches laitières
nous allons en priorité produire du
compost que nous permettent de produire
des légumes et des céréales
mais en plus de cela nous serons
capables de produire 200 mille litres de
lait et 7000 kg géantes ensuite sur les
15 hectares de céréales mais sur les 15
hectares de seria nous sommes capables
de produire 20 tonnes de céréales
panifiables alors des céréales
panifiables ce sont des céréales que
l'être humain peut consommer directement
donc nous pourrions faire du pain et de
la bière par exemple directement avec
ensuite nous prenions aussi également 40
tonnes de céréales mais qui eux ne
seraient non panifiables donc c'est à
dire qu'ils ne ne pourrait pas être
utilisés pour l'alimentation humaine
donc avec ses 40 hectares avec ses 40
tonnes de céréales
nous choisirons d'élever des poules
pondeuses alors pourquoi toujours dans
la réflexion de mieux utiliser l'espace
et les ressources pourquoi des poules
pondeuses
parce que les poules pondeuses ce soit
c'est l'animal qu'elle capable de
produire le plus de nourriture à
destination de l'être humain avec le
moins de végétaux dont grâce à ses 40
tonnes de céréales nous serions capables
de produire 700 où tous les jours toute
l'année mais c'est pas tout il faut
encore aller beaucoup plus loin dans la
démarche dans la réflexion entre chacune
de mes parcelles j'ai des espaces à
l'heure actuelle qu on ne cultive pas on
pourrait y mettre des arbres fruitiers
et ses arbres fruitiers nous permettrait
de produire plusieurs tonnes de pommes
de poires de cerises de prune de noix
noisettes enfin j'en passe mais
seulement c'est pas tout sur notre ferme
à l'heure actuelle sources tous ces
espaces entre les parcelles
il y as we km de haies et de bandes
boisées cwi km de bandes boisées et de
et s'éteint c'est un paradis pour la
faune et la flore ça c'est une première
chose mais deuxièmement si c'est une
ressource un volume de bois qui est
produit chaque année
ce volume de bois correspond aussi à une
production calorifique que nous
pourrions utiliser en le couplant aller
au combat au méthane qui serait produit
avec le compost de nos vaches
nous pourrions produisent de produire de
l'énergie calorifique et nous y voilà ça
y est je suis à grenoble transformateurs
distributeurs
je produis de la nourriture pour
insuffisance variés qualité en plus de
ça je préserve l'environnement et je
suis devenu producteur d'énergie pour un
nouveau métier acquérir encore vous ne
trouvez pas que c'est un métier
passionnant aux implications multiples
pour le devenir de notre société et on
ne s'ennuie jamais l'écart sachet sachez
une chose c'est que je n'ai fait
qu'effleurer la réalité de mon métier ça
c'est un schéma qui représente toutes
les interactions qui se passe réellement
au niveau de mon métier je les maîtrise
pas tout
mais bon on fait ce qu'on peut et j'ose
espérer que la prochaine fois que vous
croiserez un agriculteur vous le
regardez avec la détermination et l'envi
de l'accompagner dans le changement dont
nous aurons tous besoin dans notre futur
voilà